hey youtubers is Charlie said the first
part the Doctor Who finale just aired we
finally found at whom is he was
big WTF learn all about the Cybermen we
have a pretty good idea of what's going
on but there's still big mystery as to
what the doctors going to do about it
the biggest things we need to talk about
are the Missy reveal and what it means
for the future that character
so many crazy things were going on in
feels like the doctor was the only one
with his head on straight
in this episode normally it's the other
way around normally he's the madman in
the box
quick reminder new round the giveaway
start right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video
took careful for spoilers from the first
part 2 the finale if you haven't seen it
yet
but starting with top five moments okay
everybody ready
here we go number five Danny pink is
dead
when a heartbreaking way to begin the
finale especially that whole montage
milk Laura
it's hard to tell how much time had
passed but they had been cremated and
his remains so it couldn't have been
that long
a bit less than a day it passed when she
started the phone the doctor
I didn't recognize the planet the
charges as part time so if you do know
what that is just right below in the
comments
I feel like they tried extra hard to go
to some more alien places
in series aid Matt Smith came to America
Peter Cook County's going every week and
an outer space
I know there are a lot of early evil
Clark theories so whenever she said
I am owed better to her grandmother I
felt like that was during the eighties
inserted evil karbonn ties
which these me too number four clark
tried to pull a fast one on Malcolm
Tucker
in just fair warning I'm gonna cuss a
little bit because Malcolm Tucker
you understand will declare note that
the doctor is completely and fuckable
he has never been fucked before as far
as we know maybe River Song would have
something to say about that
definitely loud flashing warning lights
all over the place whenever the doctor
woke up in the volcano
giant shot out two fires of Pompeii
there a lot there's there we go back to
Pompeii
I don't know necessarily that's where
they were but I feel like that's why
they went to an active volcano
like it was the b-wing to that everybody
let me know how you feel about car on
this moment
I felt like after this scene everyone
would be totally okay
with Clyde not coming back a movie like
okay fine
you completely tried to screw the doctor
is what you get I did feel a little slap
in the face from the doctor said
known for that matter
third you betrayed me you betrayed our
trust still I don't care
he's setting himself up to be royally
screwed even if cars not the one to do
it
it did lighten the mood but I do wonder
if the doctor has another way besides
the keys to get inside the TARDIS
I understand the need to do crazy things
to try and surprise the audience
especially in a season when there's been
so many spoilers about Doctor Who
stories
but I'm not a huge fan when they
completely take everything back after
scene
it feels a little disingenuous like if
they were going to have parts for all
the targets keys
in the volcano I feel like the shit left
it that way in the doctor should have
had another way back in the TARDIS
he still could have forgiven her but the
whole scene feels like a wasted moment
when they see something never even
happened why bother writing that scene
in spending the time to film it when you
could build another scene
if you like that part scene is going to
be one of the most controversial from
cars run
anything she does in the last episode I
do have to hand it to moffett
for having the balls to try something
like that I can feel have the Phantom
rising up in rage
at the moment car owned up to it said
yeah I did that I love them
it makes me feel like she's definitely
not coming back likely just lends more
credence to the idea that
car is completely done with the doctor
the doctor just a tool to get what she
wants now
so their relationship is completely
broken regards to what the doctor says
number three welcome to the net is fear
so we family get to see what everyone's
been saying whenever they look at those
windows
jumping forward a bit we found out that
would any peak is seeing
is the inside the matrix his
consciousness was uploaded to the matrix
so it's not an actual physical place it
like cyberspace
said said that he was in a new body but
really that's not true
but he is still connected to his
physical body
like his consciousness is the kind to
explain the 3w Association
don't creamy my body don't we meet my
body don't commit my body
just explain the cremation being they
can't use their skeleton to create a
cyber man
if they're permitted the whole 3w thing
felt like a rift on the beating a drum
even though that was a poor be I did
love the welcome that means he gave the
doctor
it doesn't completely explain the
relationship between the master
and the doctor because I don't think
there was anything sexual between them
before
10 words get new personality traits when
he regenerates so I guess you could look
at that is the explanation for why
Missy is calling the doctor her
boyfriend it's a bit weird
I hope they explain it in the second
part 2 the finale the Timelord
technology she's using the matrix
is the Notre sphere and I think that was
Missy pretending to be a robot
that was the actual Missy who just the
master having fun with the doctor
number two the dead have been cyber
converted
previously the sacrament have not been
able to do this I feel like it's only
because
the master is using time where
technology to bridge that gap
that's when he's able to upload the mine
upgrade the body so to speak
I'm getting a little confused talking
about miss the Masters up
I hope you guys all understand apply
gonna be jumping back and forth between
pronounce without realizing it
right now pretty much just thinking
about the Cybermen is the talk with pain
just another way to take over the earth
the big question now
is why is the master so obsessed with
earth you go anywhere he wants in time
and space
presumably I think you just trying to
get at the doctor
the doctor loves earth so the master
wants to break his toy the Cybermen
invasion itself
you know marching down the steps the
same Paul's Cathedral is a big call back
to a second doctor episode
that time it was like the last big
episode the Cybermen we're in for a long
long time
so it's really notable call back to
doctor who history as well just a really
big thing to show
you know Saban marching through
modern-day London I like that no one is
putting out looking around
pay no attention to the crease gottman I
didn't know matters on
you think the people would flip out more
maybe they just think it's a flash mob
there was that moment during the last
episode for the doctor
kinda remarked about how children
weren't surprised by anything
like a big force grew up and they didn't
think it was a big deal maybe this is
the call back to that
people just don't think about to stab a
man walking around her big deal
in my number want to be temperamental
course missy is
the mistress so many questions right now
how did he survive the anytime
and what does this mean for the future
that character
right off the bat I don't think he's
gonna die at the end to this
there's no way they can kill the master
character up to keep bringing back
you'll find a way to escape
or she'll find a way to escape but for
all intensive purposes
during compound is run through series
niner however long he stays
Michelle Gomez will be playing this
character anti-gun agenda spotter again
and we want to let the Johnson master
but he is the show on BBC America
intruders so
there is no way he could play the
character again maybe UK me on a
background shot or something like that
that would be pretty funny
upon people miss you could turn out to
be I feel like this was at or near the
top
everyone's list there at least three
people I feel like everyone thought she
could have been
the crazies being a splinter version
Aclara which is why everyone was going
crazy with the car WTF moments from the
finale trailer
then there was a female version the
master in there was the Ronnie
to a three-time ladies I do like that
Missy
said time lady it's been a long time
since we've seen on the show
so I am glad that one's back with the
benefits West just in terms in the
future the character
I think that after we get to this finale
we're not just gonna keep seeing her
come back
all the time unity in the series 3 in
series for
we didn't see him in that many episodes
so we should all start thinking about
how she is going to escape at the end
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and let me know
how do you feel about that Missy
mistress reveal like a stink about that
here some the Easter eggs I spotted
soap for step obviously was the fires of
Pompeii which I mentioned
active volcano very dangerous one of the
only ways to destroy a tard is key
then there's the matrix the last time we
saw that was actually in a valued
episode
during that episode the master to
control the matrix Ian
attain the Kia wrestle on I don't know
they'll explain it
but at the time that was the only way to
get inside the matrix
was to have to keep grass lawn hopefully
they'll explain that in the second part
2 the finale
I know there were some theories about
Missy being a virgin at the valued
so this is about as close as you're
gonna get when we saw the shot in the
afterlife
it looked a lot like pete's world the
alternate reality where the Sabres
industry cyber men were created
it just felt like a visual reference to
that the second paper was by when the
funniest Easter eggs
while this wearing just a giant shout
out to Malcolm Tucker
and like I said the 3 W's felt like a
bit of a reference to the beating the
drums
I was a fundamental part of the
character the beating a drum so
it's unclear whether not now that he's
regenerated into a woman that they're
gonna continue doing that
if you spotted any other restricting the
episode that I didn't list just reading
below in the comments
on all again the finale a solid a for
just huge WTF reveals
of italy has some stones on and it
earned a Master new mistress
with the absurdity really well was
deliver on excitement
first off you have a companion
completely betraying the doctor
huge WTF I can't remember the last time
a companion went that crazy
River Song is a companion kinda she was
evil before she became a companion
did feel like Jenna comment evil
performance as pie one of the better
ones that she's turned in
so all you had to her for that Mary
Poppins hat of
Michelle Gomez to for her performance
playing the master is just like playing
the doctor
there been so many people to do it
before you you have to find a way to
make your own want the same time keeping
a lot of familiar things about the
character
the Masters kinda like in evil near the
doctor getting crazy mad man in a box
being
a mad woman in a box this episode was
mostly her dancing
around the doctor just having fun so
I'll be interested to see if she goes
full evil in the second half crazy
master is a lot of fun
but I like playful master a lot better
so hopefully she'll keep it under your
hat just a little bit
when it's all said and done I'm hoping
we get to see her in the Christmas
special
at least in some way all the people that
are theorizing about Jenna common
leaving I feel like dat is when the
transition would be made
so just a quick reminder cuny person
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
that
post all your questions in the comments
until the ban the doctor whose ending so
soon but
it's really only couple weeks before the
Christmas special like if I can be that
long
those asking I will be doing more
Sherlock series 4 videos
whenever doctor who is done they will be
filming that Christmas special the 2015
Christmas special
in January so why keep thinking about
the big WTF miss you reveal
you can click here for the Q&A I the
inefficiencies are posted
in click here for my Doctor Who episode
10 video thank you so much watching
football halfpipe and I will see you
guys tonight